in general
[Music]
good morning everybody
and thank you for joining us today I'd
like to thank President Trump for
hosting this ceremony and let me say
it's an honor to serve under a president
who is so strongly a supporter of law
enforcement and has the back of police
officers and first responders Thank You
mr. president
we've come together to recognize the
extraordinary actions of a 11 fellow
citizens the president has chosen to
honor five civilians from Texas who
displayed an extraordinary degree of
care for their fellow man putting their
own lives at risk we also honor six
police officers from Ohio who put
themselves between a gunman and a crowd
of innocent civilians for the people out
and Dayton that night these officers
were the thin blue line between life and
death the actions of this these six
officers show that while that line may
be thin it is very strong established in
2001 the Medal of Valor is our nation's
highest public safety award officers
across the nation are nominated by their
peers but only a handful are selected to
receive this honor traditionally this
process occurs only once a year however
the law permits the Attorney General to
expand the total number of recipients
when exceptional instances of bravery
arise and so that's what we did this
year in my eyes and in the eyes of our
nation this special recognition is
warranted valor is a word we don't
commonly hear people can show courage
and bravery confronting many different
challenges in life but valor connotes a
willing putting oneself in mortal danger
to protect others we humans have a
powerful instinct to flee from peril it
takes a special kind of courage a deep
sense of duty and extraordinary
character to overcome these impulses and
for the sake of others to run toward the
danger and we thank God that on that
horrible night in Dayton we had men of
these qualities as we honor the Valor of
these men
we must recognize that we cannot take
them and their brothers and sisters in
law enforcement for granted
serving as a police officer is the
toughest job in our country and as they
put themselves on the line to keep us
safe
they deserve our gratitude and support
we are grateful not just for the courage
of these officers but also of their
families and we salute those families
here today you encounter long days and
restless nights still you endure them
for all of us our very ability to live
normal lives to go to school to go to
work and to pursue our aspirations
without fear is only because of your
sacrifice the brave actions of today's
honorees from Dayton and from El Paso
should awaken in all of us a new
dedication to service and selflessness
on behalf of our communities so god
bless our heroes and their families and
Thank You mr. president for the
opportunity to success to express our
appreciation today
[Applause]
well I want to thank the Attorney
General for not only this today but for
doing an incredible job thank you very
much bill appreciate it today I'm
honored to welcome you to the White
House as we recognize 11 extraordinary
American heroes these incredible
Patriots responded to the worst violence
and most barbaric hatred with the best
of American courage character and
strength faced with grave and harrowing
threats the men and women standing
behind us step forward to save the lives
of their fellow Americans few people
could have done and even would have done
what they did in a few moments I will
award six police officers from Dayton
Ohio with our nation's highest public
safety award the Medal of Valor
I will also honor five Americans from El
Paso Texas with certificates of
commendation recognizing these civilians
who displayed tremendous bravery the
light from these intrepid souls defied
the darkness and confronted the most
sinister danger would you all please
join me in expressing our deepest
gratitude and highest admiration to
these unbelievably exceptional Americans
thank you
[Applause]
we're also joined by Senator John Cornyn
and several members of my cabinet and I
want to thank you all for being here
John thank you very much most
importantly to the families of our
heroes you understand better than anyone
the difference your loved ones have made
in the lives of so many Americans we
treasure you and we really do thank you
from the bottom of our hearts again
thank you very much
great job one month ago America
witnessed horribie unbelief on Saturday
August 3rd at a Walmart in El Paso Texas
the soulless and bigoted monster killed
22 innocent people and wounded 27 others
happened very quickly it was a racist
attack motivated by pure evil hatred the
next day in Dayton Ohio a vile and
wicked murderer stole nine lives and
injured 34 others our nation is shocked
and enraged by these inhuman and
sadistic acts of bloodshed we fail to
comprehend how any person could be so
warped by malice and contempt every
heart breaks for the families who lost
precious loved ones and every American
grieves for those who were so cruelly
taken from us
in the midst of such profound anguish
one memory fills us with hope when evil
showed its hideous face Americans of all
walks of life rose up than they did they
rose up they defied fear they stared
down death to protect the innocent and
stand tall they did just for righteous
and for good several days after the
shootings the First Lady and I visited
both cities we met with first responders
hospital staff survivors and families we
will never forget the unity and love we
saw in those communities and at those
hospitals it was incredible in Ohio I
had the privilege of meeting the six
state and police officers who without a
moment's hesitation
immediately and courageously engaged the
gunman ending his attack and rescuing
countless lives who knew and who can
even understand how many lives would
have been taken if they didn't act so
quickly just after 1:00 a.m. on August
4th these officers were patrolling the
streets of downtown Dayton when the
killer opened fire into an innocent crab
the shooter continued firing as he ran
down a sidewalk pack with people
sergeant william knight was stationed in
his cruiser about 150 feet away he heard
the gunfire jumped out of his car and
quickly returned fire meanwhile officer
Bryan ralphus ran directly towards the
shooter and into the onslaught of
incoming bullets then offices Jeremy
Campbell Vincent Carter
Ryan Abell and David den ling'er moved
in engaging the shooter at close range
calling upon years of training in the
span of an instant millions of Americans
saw the video footage of these officers
calmly charging forward in the midst of
chaos and constant fire without a
thought for their own safety they stood
Square to the target executed their
mission and brought down to the
murderers with precision gunfire it was
just before that maniac was ready to
enter a very crowded restaurant and bar
within 32 seconds of the start of the
attack these six officers ended the
violent rampage and saved countless
lives today it is my immense honor to
award the Medal of Valor to those law
enforcement heroes sergeant william
knight and officers brian ralphus Jeremy
Campbell Vincent Carter
Ryan Abell and David den Langer to each
of you we are in awe of your swift
response
sterling professionalism and rock-solid
nerves of steel on behalf of our entire
nation we thank you for your remarkable
and heroic actions in the line of duty
and we just want to thank you so much
what a great job you've done thank you
very much
[Applause]
today we are also honoring five
Americans who risk their lives to save
others during the brutal attack at the
Walmart in El Paso Texas Walmart store
manager Robert Evans was outside the
store entrance when he heard the gunman
fire his first shot Robert instantly
alerted employees of the active shooter
he saw the killer heading towards the
store so he raced inside and directed
customers toward the nearest emergency
exits helping hundreds escape to safety
incredible Robert you exemplify noble
leadership and selfless service thank
you very much Robert
thank you
Walmart employee Gilbert Serna
heard Roberts Alert over the radio and
immediately without hesitation guided
dozens of shoppers to refuge through a
rear exit boosting some people over a
12-foot wall and hiding others in
shipping containers so smart to think of
that who would think of that under these
circumstances a lot of people would just
run for their lives he cleared out the
back area of the store a minute before
the shooter got there Gilbert your
unwavering resolve inspires us all thank
you very much Gilbert great job Maricela
luna was managing the McDonald's inside
the Walmart when the murderer burst into
the entrance she quickly gathered
customers from the lobby and led them to
refrigerators and other hiding places
shielding them from the shooters line of
sight Thank You maricella for racing to
rescue others from grave danger thank
you very much
McDonnell supervisor Angelica Silva was
working at another location when she got
word of the active shooting she drove
straight to the scene to check on her
employees upon arriving angelicus two
people in the parking lot who were very
very badly wounded she alerted first
responders and helped save the life of
one of those severely injured victims
Angelica we thank God you were there
thank you very much thank you Chris
grant was picking out snacks for his
kids when he suddenly saw the murder of
firing at innocent shop a few aisles
away from him
Chris grabbed listen to this soda
bottles and anything else in front of
him and began hurling them at the gunman
distracting him from the other shoppers
and causing the shooter to turn toward
Chris and fire at Chris whereby Chris
suffered two very serious gunshot wounds
but he is recovering well and we wish
him the best his family is here so
please thank Chris for us think of that
in the darkest moments of danger and
despair God calls the bravest to action
these eleven individuals answered the
call they stared down evil they put love
of neighbor above life itself and we are
blessed by their courage we are honored
by their presence we are overwhelmed by
their example and we are forever
inspired by the goodness of their hearts
the grace of their souls and the
enduring greatness of their deeds to
every one of the heroes we recognize
today thank you and God bless you all
thank you very much
now I would like to ask the military
aide to come forward and read the
citations please
the medal of valor is presented to the
following individuals for their bravery
and composure and the face of an armed
Island intent on the murder of innocent
civilians in Dayton Ohio on August 4
2019 their quick and decisive actions in
the face of extreme danger neutralized
the gunman within seconds protecting the
lives of hundreds of people sergeant
william knight
Officer Brian Rufus
[Applause]
Officer Jeremy Campbell
[Applause]
officer Vincent Carter
[Applause]
officer Ryan de Bell
[Applause]
officer david den ling'er
well the middle of battle of recipients
please take your seats and the
certificate of commendation recipients
please join the President on stage the
certificate of commendation is presented
to the following individuals for acting
selflessly and fearlessly to save
hundreds from a hateful gunman who
opened fire at a Walmart in El Paso
Texas on August 3rd 2019
each of these courageous civilians could
have escaped to safety during the
massacre but they instead put their own
lives in jeopardy to help their
neighbors find refuge and access
desperately needed medical attention mr.
Robert Evans
[Applause]
mr. Gilbert Serna
[Applause]
miss Marcella Luna
[Applause]
miss Angelica Silva
[Applause]
accepting on behalf of her son Chris
grant miss mini-grants
[Applause]
with the Medal of Valor of recipients
please join the President on stage for
one last group photo
[Applause]
[Music]